health officials are getting creative in
how they convince hesitant americans to
get the covet vaccine according to the
cdc the daily average for vaccinations
has dropped 20
since the start of the month a worrying
trend omar villafranca is following this
for us in baton rouge louisiana
omar good morning to you in west
virginia they will actually give you a
hundred dollar savings bond
if you get the shot what incentives are
being offered there where you are
well tony they're still doing mass
vaccination sites like this one here
behind me but for some people it's
just not convenient so they're doing
things like shots for shots and think of
that as a
vodka for a vaccine at the bar and
they're having to get creative because
less than one third of louisiana's
population
has received the first dose
where did you get your first shot
i got it at a local bar 23-year-old
brandon bro went to a bar with friends
and ended up vaccinated it was a shot
for shot
nights in baton rouge the shots for
shots program is run by relief
a telehealth company the shots program
came to this bar on tuesday night
where bartender curtis johnson had a
shot waiting for him
moderna straight from the syringe why
didn't you go to a vaccination site or a
doctor's office
well the convenience is what spoke to me
most today the fact that it's literally
five feet away from me
i work late night i've either just never
found the time or just been too
exhausted to go out
that type of convenience makes a
difference in reaching the unvaccinated
says relief ceo bashal vasanji people
trust people that they're familiar with
and so
you know if we're friends i could come
to you and say hey the process was easy
here's what it is
and it might get you one step closer to
getting vaccinated but success
varies by night at soji only a handful
of people got the shot
do these type of events help even if
it's just a few people
they do they absolutely do dr joseph
cantor
is the louisiana state health officer
right now his state is administering
less than
70 percent of the first doses delivered
from the federal government
we're taking the kitchen sink approach
here no idea is bad
every idea is worth considering cantor
says when it comes to the vaccine
hesitant
most are not against vaccination most
people just have
questions they're on the fence they want
to talk it out they want to wait and see
it's all about empowering trusted
messengers
in communities cantor says the best
messenger tends to be people's own
doctors
and that's the case for 42 year old
katie oligon who has not gotten
vaccinated
are you a hard no no i'm not a hard no
you're not a heart not a hard no
i was a hard no initially i believe in
science and i believe in masks i just
don't know how i feel about the vaccine
i don't get flu shots
but our kids are fully vaccinated so
it's not that so that's just kind of
where i am
state health officials admit that people
are tired of hearing from the government
telling them to come get a shot so now
they're trying to move their message to
new people
church leaders so they can get that
message on sunday and the
saturday football faithful they want to
get people involved with
lsu football to try to get that message
out keep in mind lsu football and scc
football
is pretty big down here in louisiana
anthony
got to meet people where they are omar
and sometimes they are in a bar
as long as the bartender is not given
the shots